feeling pretty good I'm in a good mood
thought I heard my neighbors having sex
this morning but it was just somebody
walking downstairs in their flip-flops
still pretty good pretty good I was
thinking about getting married so I
looked it up and I saw a survey that
said 70% of men cheat on their wives I
didn't know that 70 that's a lot and
those are just the ones that put it on
the survey like oh yeah that's right
survey man comedies going great people
seem to think I'm a nice guy and stuff
but I don't really think it's that I'm a
nice guy I think it's just that I'm from
the south and I treat everybody like
they have a gun and it works great
people be like what you think about the
election I'm like what did you think
about no I don't understand politics I
don't understand laws like I think the
weirdest law ever is the age of consent
law and I'm glad it's long I'm just a
little creepy that it's different in
different states I think that's the
creepiest thing I've ever heard of and I
know it's creepy cuz I just brought it
up here and it just got quieter than
it's been all night but someone brought
it up the first day of America they're
all sitting around making rules when
guys like alright so no sex with anybody
under 18 a guy in the back slick that's
more of a states rights issue don't you
think
[Applause]
and that's why I think we have
Republicans and Democrats because
Democrats go knows sex with kids and
Republicans go what's a kid before we
make a man the town I'm from Royston
it's very small only two thousand people
there one stoplight in my neighborhood
growing up and they added another one
this year and my dad thought that was
government overreach pretty liberal
stoplight
they made deliverance near my town
deliverance and here's all you need to
know about Royston we are proud of that
tell everybody made deliverance right
down the road I'm like that sounds like
a threat I'm told my family they're
always trying to give me ideas for skits
and they're all bad they're all real bad
and they're proud of them they're always
like oh I got a good skit for you so uh
you go up there and I'm like I know
where I go now I'll go up there and be
like hey y'all think the chick-fil-a and
heavens open on Sunday
it's a big skit sometimes they'll throw
a big long boring story at me around the
dinner table they'll all take turns
saying the most empty thing their whole
year and they're proud of that - they're
all Caleb you're gonna love this one
me and Carol were out driving and we
drove past the Dairy Queen and the sign
said lizards wizards a Dairy Queen so
Carol says oh it probably it was
blizzards and the bee fell off and we
just laughed we said if Caleb oh he
would have loved that typo we said he
should put back in his ski and they've
all got guns so I put them in the skit
[Music]
thank you so much you guys are great
you